this is a completely impromptu
livestream because of the breaking news
that disgraced former national security
adviser Michael Flynn has now agreed or
is open to the idea of taking immunity
in order to testify in the investigation
into collusion between Donald Trump and
Russia I don't know that people are
understanding just how major this is and
that is exactly what I want to talk
about today and I apologize for the
camera totally impromptu stream it's all
it's because of breaking news that I'm
doing this and I get it's probably kind
of dark and the angles weird on the
camera I was not prepared to do this and
the idea here is listen if you haven't
done anything wrong you wouldn't offer
to testify in exchange for immunity
because the obvious question is immunity
from what okay so we will be talking
about this super chat is on what else I
will be doing live shoutouts and
thank-yous to people who sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership and it is it is stunning that
I still have people on the left
obviously people on the right are
telling me David there's no story here
Sean Spicer saying hey Trump Russia is a
done deal it's over but even some people
on the Left are saying that to me people
on the Left are saying David there is no
story here how is there no story when
the national security adviser that
resigned in shame after lying about his
contacts with Russian officials is now
saying I would take criminal immunity to
testify into this entire Trump Russia
thing you don't do that unless there's
something to testify about so welcome to
everybody who's joining the live stream
please people saying by the way that the
video is bad but the audio is good this
is totally impromptu
I can't do a damn thing about it I just
plugged in my headphones and went live
and we're getting what we're getting so
yes indeed folks we you know that what's
amazing to me about what's going on
right now in this Trump Russia thing and
really in general with this Trump
administration is that even like the
secondary and tertiary scandals if it
were Obama whose biggest scandal was he
wore a tan suit to talk about something
serious if this were Obama who had even
the tertiary scandals that Donald Trump
has it would be 24/7 news on all right
wing media and I just took a screenshot
and I'm gonna share it to my Instagram
later by the way follow me on Instagram
David Pakman Fox News is covering that
Mike Mike Pence won't have dinner alone
with women other than his wife I the
news is breaking I get back I was out
with some friends I start looking at
who's covering what and Tucker Carlson
on Fox News his big story as Michael
Flynn is saying I I will exchange
immunity to testify in this
investigation into Trump Russia the
headline is VP pence won't dine alone
with other women so what does this tell
us it tells us a number of things it
tells us number one that right-wing
media just will not cover what is going
on here they're just not going to tell
you what's going on and the idea is the
same idea that Sean Spicer had yesterday
during his press conference where he
basically said the entire Trump Russia
thing is is done everybody's been
cleared there's nothing to look at which
obviously isn't true we've got a house
investigation which is bogus I mean
Devon Nunez it's not a serious
investigation but we've got it we've got
the Senate investigation which may not
be that much better it might be better
it might not be better and then we have
at minimum the FBI investigation so it's
it's it's a total distraction technique
and again when your former national
security adviser is saying if you give
me immunity I will testify he's done
something
he has done something wrong and I don't
know how far this is going to go I was
watching a little bit of Rachel Maddow
and she was saying you know it's not
clear if this is going to be presidency
ending or not but it's getting very
serious and you know Ivanka Trump being
hired without a salary by the Trump
administration if it were Obama it would
be a major scandal but in the time of
Trump it barely even registers I mean
we've been covering that story and the
anti-nepotism laws and everything that's
going on but the the secondary and
tertiary scandals barely register it is
it is stunning
truly truly stunning big thank you to
Gus did who just signed up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership membership thank you so much
Gus also thanks to thanks to Josh
McKenzie who has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership membership
is the number one funding source for our
show and we have a coupon code which is
I voted 17 and it will give you a 40%
discount off of membership if you use
the coupon code and that is it it's big
Lee tremendous I mean I don't I don't
know how else I can say it we are mostly
funded by membership and I appreciate
everybody who's been signing up and and
absolutely will continue doing live
thank-yous and shout outs to people as
they sign up
think about the comments by the way
we're talking about Michael Flynn
disgraced shamed former Trump national
security advisor Michael Flynn who
resigned in shame after it was revealed
that he lied about the contents of his
conversations with Russian ambassador to
the US Sergei Kiss lyac he resigned in
shame
he now has said he is willing to
cooperate with the congressional
investigation into the Trump Russia
collusion scandal in exchange for
immunity which of course tells us that
he must at least believe he may have
done something criminal
otherwise why why would he make that
offer right we're talking about that and
we're taking questions and and welcome
to everybody who's joining me on the
livestream there's so many directions
that we could go in this conversation
and I keep going got a situation here
that should be bipartisan we've got a
country that has an election which may
have been sort of subjugated or
jeopardized by a foreign entity you have
numerous individuals numerous
individuals in the administration who
have either implicitly or explicitly
admitted that they have been in contact
direct contact with Russian Russian
agents how is anybody on the left still
denying that this is a thing
and by the way we have moderators and I
know and there it is our a reliable
moderator our D are starting to block
people the blocks are free folks you you
might be able to get away with it for 10
seconds as you just did but it's not
going to work and I have fully deputized
if you're one of these people who after
the stream is going to go to david
pakman.com and email me and say oh david
free speech is being restricted because
on your youtube live stream somebody
blocked me don't expect a response for
me
okay the moderators have been deputized
and they have been given specific
instructions we're all on the same page
here this is not an issue of free speech
you're just not going to show up and
troll the live streams okay you're just
not going to do it and the moderators
are managing this in a big lee
tremendous way okay and they are it's
all happening let me put it that way I
say it with peace and love okay let me
let me get back to what I was saying how
are any leftists at this point saying
that the entire Trump Russia thing is
nothing
I still get it's fewer and fewer but I
still get tweets from people saying
David Trump Russia is nothing stop
talking about it it's nothing
so far we've not had any moment where we
go oh you know what we went too far
on Russia we've got to go back because
we made a mistake
every single aspect of the Trump Russia
story is either not disproven or proven
so far and even when we look at the
Trump Russia dossier the blackmail
dossier which was put together by widely
respected mi6 former mi6 agent
Christopher Steele yeah
Trump having a urine fetish hasn't been
confirmed but every single week more and
more aspect more and more elements of
the Trump blackmail dossier has been
confirmed so you know I say this
seriously explain to me in what way the
Trump Russia story is nothing and you
know we have to talk about straw men
here as well if you are arguing well
there might be a trump Russia story but
Russian hacking didn't impact the
election we are like months past that at
this point okay at this point it doesn't
matter whether Russian hacking and
releasing of information damaging to
Hillary Clinton impacted the results
were way beyond that right if Donald
Trump and Michael Flynn and Jeff
Sessions and Jared Kushner and Carter
Page and Roger stone I mean listen
listen to the list here that I'm telling
you if they coordinated with Russia to
try to have an advantage in an American
election it doesn't matter whether
Russian hacking of John Podesta's emails
change the election and I think that
this is what a lot of people on the Left
may be missing and again it's very few
people every single day fewer and fewer
people are emailing me saying David
there's no story here a few people are
but but fewer and fewer big thank you to
John Skinner who has signed up for
membership at david pakman.com
membership big thank you to John Condry
who has signed up for membership at
david pakman.com slash membership both
of them using the coupon code
I voted 17 we have a set of member
benefits that is huge I don't know how
else to describe it and it includes a
daily bonus show just for our paid
subscribers and even if you use the
coupon code
I voted 17 you get a 40% discount but
you get a hundred percent of the
benefits okay and we do a lot of funny
stuff on the bonus show on the march
28th bonus show we tried vegan cheese
on-air on March 21st I told what is now
infamously called the st. Patrick's Day
public urination story the bonus show is
a great time so sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership okay
people in the chat saying steven crowder
is crushing me here's what i would
encourage you to do okay
youtube revenue is not based on
subscribers youtube revenue is based on
views because if someone subscribes an
ad doesn't play and on youtube you make
money when ads play go to
socialblade.com and do a comparison
between the david pakman show channel
and stephen Crowder's channel and
compare views not subscribers and then
come back and tell me with a straight
face or a straight keyboard to call it
what you want that steven crowder is
crushing us ok so just look at the data
this is not my opinion the great thing
is we have data that we can look at
check out socialblade.com we've got a 10
British Pound super chat from Scottish
racer 98 who says Flynn must have done
something
also he must have dirt on the whole
white house not heard and he knew that
nigel Faraj helped Trump at rallies and
he has ties to RT and weekly WikiLeaks I
have no clue what this super chat is
about it's not a question so I feel ok
just reading it and sort of moving on
Flynn must have done something
also he must have dirt on the whole
white
house also not heard any new that Nigel
Faraj helped trumpet rallies and he has
ties to RT and WikiLeaks since you
mentioned RT I'll take this as an
opportunity to mention that segment
producer Noah Ferguson and I are working
on a fake news long-form piece it's
gonna be about 22 to 24 minutes and
we're going to talk about what is fake
news
what isn't fake news what's the
difference between propaganda news and
fake news what is the original fake news
hint it has to do with religion it's
going to be a really really great piece
okay so please stay tuned for that and
we're gonna be dealing with that on the
show I think we have it scheduled not
for this coming week but for next week
okay so as far as the Michael Flynn
thing and and in terms of what's next
III you know I don't like to my Irish
show is not like a conspiracy theory
show so even today we did a story which
you might find industry and interesting
which is about is Donald Trump suffering
from cognitive decline that could be
associated with early stage dementia or
Alzheimer's okay we're not doing it in
Alex Jones voice and offering you
colloidal silver in between right I'm
basically coming to and I'm saying hey
listen there are ways to measure early
stage cognitive decline if you go back
and look at an analysis of how Ronald
Reagan spoke during his presidency
versus how George HW Bush spoke during
his pregnancy or not pregnancy
presidency you can identify an objective
difference and let's apply that to
Donald Trump and here's some data which
could suggest that Trump maybe is
experiencing early stage Alzheimer's or
dementia so we don't do conspiracy
theory stuff right but at this point
it's very hard if you've been following
this the entire time to believe that
there's just nothing to see here and
some people say David you're being
conspiratorial I
think the only way that you could have
that perspective is if you're not paying
attention or you're ideologically
committed to denying what is out there
you know I just don't get how else you
could come to that conclusion Karen
Jones has sent a to British pound super
chat saying can the White House stop
Flynn testifying okay so looking at the
Sally Yates situation gives us a little
bit of idea about this if you let me see
how I can put this if you take the White
House said we didn't take any action to
stop Sally Yates from testifying the
literal interpretation of that is they
didn't formally prevent her from
testifying but more than likely like if
we sort of think through what likely
happened they probably made pretty clear
that it wouldn't be seen favorably for
her to testify so can the White House
legally stop Flynn from testifying
there's probably a mechanism where they
could try to invoke executive privilege
in some way all the legal experts have
already said that probably won't won't
be able to there doesn't really make
sense given the circumstances but my
real concern is what I think some people
in the chat are suggesting which is I
hope Sally Yates or Mike Flynn don't end
up accidentally stabbing themselves in
the back ten times right if you know
what I'm talking about when it comes to
many of the players that that are
involved in this so that that's sort of
my concern it's not so much the
executive privilege thing or sort of a
diplomatic or bureaucratic way of
stopping him from testifying but you
know you don't want to end up
accidentally shooting yourself in the
back twice or something like that we
know that those accidents can can really
be damaging to your ability to speak out
hey by the way super chat is on and it
sounds like people I'm seeing some
people in the chat who are saying don't
pay for super chat I don't know what the
store I don't know why people are so
upset about super chat but by all means
send those super chats in we've already
had two or three and most live streams I
do get somewhere around I don't know 15
or so
super chats I would say there seems to
be confusion in the chat about both
former producer Louis and current
producer pat known as vegan Pat or
Keurig Pat Louis left the show about six
months ago he did not want to live in
Boston any longer and if people missed
that story we've got a bunch of videos
about it we've got like a Louis going
away day where we did a durian tasting
bla bla bla bla bla
so there that's I don't want to be labor
that that's gone on and Pat isn't here
right now because Pat and I don't live
together it was interesting when people
used to think that louis louis and i
probably lived together because louis
worked on the show but now lewis had his
own place i I have my own place and
since Pat doesn't live with me he's not
on the on the live streams okay let me
pause there and number one let me say
thank you to Tyrone Moss who has signed
up at david pakman.com slash membership
using the coupon code I voted 17 I also
want to say thank you to Clare Hill
Clare Hill has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership there's a
coupon code it saves you 40% the coupon
code is I voted 17 and I am glad to
mention that as we are approaching 800
people or so on the live stream you know
there's this interesting thing that's
been going on with the live streams I'll
get back in a second to the Michael
Flynn stuff initially I would do these
live streams off of my phone the way I'm
doing right now and they would get
sometimes 500 live streamers and
sometimes 1,500 live streamers and
people said hey David you should start
scheduling the live streams ahead of
time people will see that you have a
live stream coming up it'll increase the
audience of the live stream so I did
that and when I streamed from my laptop
with my nicer mic and camera and the
entire thing and sometimes again we get
1,500 people on the live stream and
sometimes we only get 500 so I've
actually not noticed that the live
streams do better when I schedule them
in advance certainly when I have you
know access
to a better internet connection and my
nicer camera and mic the per day about I
think we're back I think I might be back
on the air hmm can anybody tell me
whether we're back I'm back okay good
alright listen this was an impromptu
live stream because of breaking news so
real quick Matt Oh a tow 670 sent a $2
super chat saying how do we vote to
lower Trump's approval rating you can't
really vote to lower his approval rating
but if you get a call from Gallup
polling you then you can say I don't
approve of the job that Trump is doing
$2 super chat from crystal s-saying
gusoff er to conf
Russ agents is WikiLeaks - I'm having
trouble understanding that when I guess
the question is whether WikiLeaks is a
Rudge Russian agent or was in touch with
Russian agents at this point who knows
it's very very hard to say what is going
on and sadly we have lost nearly half of
our audience because of that
interruption but I'm doing the best I
can
we've got a to Australian dollar super
chat from Cameron Llewellyn saying is
immunity for Flynn's investigation or
wider one immunity would basically be
that if Flynn testifies in the
investigation by Congress into the Trump
Russia scandal he will not be prosecuted
for anything related to that
investigation if he went out and killed
someone unrelated to the investigation
he's not getting immunity for that right
so it's specifically related to to that
investigation I think I'm understanding
the question that you're asking there
big big thank you tremendous thank you
going out - oh boy this is a tough name
let me see if I can pronounce this Ruki
rukia - tak para Rukia - tuk para who
has signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership with the coupon code I voted
17 also Randall Phillips that's a much
easier name Randle Phillips has signed
up at david pakman.com slash and members
and I appreciate that big time so I
found out I saw a few things they're
asking David how do you how did you find
out about the Michael Flynn story like
literally what what am i doing how do I
find out about it I was out with some
friends and all of a sudden a friend
walked in and said Michael Flynn has
just asked for is open to immunity to
testifying if he testifies in this
investigation and then we all get on our
phones and start looking at all the
articles on reddit on Google News etc
and I think at this point even Fox News
is covering it I mentioned that earlier
and I took a screenshot after the news
broke I went and started looking at some
different streams and and Tucker Carlson
had the block Buster's story of Mike
Pence being unwilling to dine alone with
other women the of course incredibly
important story however if you go to Fox
news.com now you see that a Michael
Flynn is in talks to testify if assured
immunity you go to cnn.com Flynn wants
immunity you go to MSNBC calm what is
their headline right now I'm guessing
it's the exact same thing
Flynn asks for immunity quote has a
story to tell and if you look on Google
News you've got one two three four five
six seven dozens actually dozens and
dozens of articles about this and it
seems like it is not looking
particularly good for the Trump
administration when it comes to this I
do want to restate by the way I know
that there's people I think when I was
talking about this some people were
disconnected I was sort of joking in a
way when I said I hope Michael Flynn or
Sally Yates don't end up accidentally
stabbing themselves in the back ten
times but can can we really is it in the
chat do you consider it a conspiracy
theory at this point to say I'm worried
about the physical security of Michael
Flynn if
he is indeed willing to testify in this
way I don't think it's in any way
conspiratorial or outrageous given what
we've seen so far
and I see some people saying it's not
conspiratorial few people saying it is
conspiratorial I think given what's
going on and by the way the number of
suspicious Russian deaths that have gone
on what is a conspiracy at this point to
me the conspiracy at this point is
pretending like there's no Russia story
truly truly stunning let me talk about
some of what's going on the david
patten.com slash our EDD i.t we now have
over 3,200 of our viewers and listeners
participating there on a regular basis
and I encourage you to sign up there a
lot of discussion about our story on
Trump and potential early stage
Alzheimer's or dementia check out that
story we have a number of stories there
about Michael Flynn offering to testify
about Russia for immunity we have a
number of threads talking about the
constant scandals that our producer
vegan Pat or curing Pat or Patrick C
Ford have been has been involved in
including coffee and so many other
things so there's a lot of interesting
stuff going on at david pakman.com slash
read it we have just like on the youtube
streams we have moderators that have
been deputized to control the trolling
we also have moderators on the reddit
discussion forum so don't be worried
about too much trolling we've got things
pretty well under control
$5 super chat from Nicholas Benny
Nicholas Benny says hate to bring up old
news but did you read Laurie Penny's
article about Milo in Opelousas story
being an allegory for Peter Pan and the
lost boys Nicholas I have not read it
however I'm bookmarking it right now to
read after the stream we also have a ten
british pound
super chat from scottish racer racer 98
who I think is clarifying an earlier
super chat saying sorry mistyped Nigel
Faraj is a UK MEP who was speaking at
trumps
next the Trump during the election at
the same time he was appearing on Russia
today also discussions of hosting a new
show okay yeah I don't know the full
backstory on the interplay between nigel
farage and and RT i've seen an
appearance he did on RT although i don't
fully know what the connections are
there but needless to say RT will be
certainly mentioned in our upcoming
piece on fake news and propaganda news
clarf one two three four has sent a to
australian dollar super chat saying
would i debate Kuklinski on russia i
assume Kuklinski is the secular talk
equivalent of david Cookman i don't you
know do i i don't know what you talk
about debate but i'm obviously willing
to talk to you i'm in touch with a lot
of these people off air kyle kolinsky
and dave rubin and you know a lot of
these different people I always am
willing to have a conversation about
whatever issue they want to talk about
you know I've never if we're gonna have
a just a cot you know a respectful
exchange of ideas which may be differing
ideas absolutely absolutely I'm willing
to have a conversation about that
Kuklinski you know I don't know anything
about that that seems to have as much
credibility as David Kirkman a Curtis
Roger sent a $5 super chat does this and
I assume Curtis means the Michael Flynn
willing to testify in exchange for
immunity does this increase that you
think there is no doubt that you were if
you were of the mindset that we may well
see a trump impeachment or resignation
under threat of impeachment or likely
impeachment there is no doubt that when
your national security adviser who
resigned in shame after lying about his
contacts with Russia once he says he's
willing to testify in exchange for
immunity
in and of itself it doesn't increase the
likelihood of a resignation or
impeachment but it certainly tells us
that there is a major story here which
is probably not going to be favorable to
the Trump administration Phobos moon has
sent a one Canadian dollar super chat
with no question nor comment I do want
to send major thank-yous these are like
believe me folks these are huge thank
yous going to Danielle Fedor Co who has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership using the coupon code
I voted 17 and also Neil Stewart who has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership using the coupon code
I voted 17 just a few interesting things
that you might want to look at when you
sign up we do a daily extra show just
for paid subscribers called the bonus
show it's more casual than the regular
show we do technology stories more
international stories etc but we also
sometimes do things that are not
political at all on the march 21st bonus
show I told the story that has now gone
down and infamy as the st. Patrick's Day
public urination story I would encourage
you to check that out also the March
28th bonus show we had a viewer named
Ashley who sent us knowing that vegan
producer Pat is vegan sent us sent us
vegan cheese and we tried it on air and
it was an interesting segment so check
that out after you sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership people
asking about Ben Dickson and April 19th
ah listen I have not been authorized so
people might know that Ben Dixon of the
Benjamin Dixon show hosts his show out
of the David Pakman show studio and
actually you know I might as well tell
you about this there's a lot of stuff
going on behind the scenes with studio
upgrades but I'll get to that in a
second I have no clue what it is that
Ben has said about April 19th so I'm not
going to comment but I'm guessing can
someone tell me what Ben has said I
don't want to speak out of turn has he
teased something for April 19th let me
just say that you know Ben's doing a
great job and what I'm trying to say I
don't I don't want to overstep
is been on the chat if Ben is watching
the livestream tell me what you've said
so that maybe I can say something
without you know violating this
overstepping any lines mmm I don't know
it doesn't seem like anybody I'm not
sure what Ben has said anyway April 19th
Ben Dixon yes absolutely
Clarke 1 2 3 4 sent a to Australian
dollar super chat saying saying come
visit the david pakman show discord yes
there is a David Pakman show discord
server I don't actually know the details
of it our great moderators on the David
Pakman show
reddit have set it up there is
information at david pakman.com slash
reddit about the discord server i have
not joined it as of right now and you
can check that out
couple people saying dangerous you're
not is asking how to sign up with a
credit card
for membership super easy when you go to
david pakman.com slash membership and
select your membership level you select
credit card when you're paying for it
and that is basically it which is
exactly what heather Taverner heather
Tavener rather has done using the coupon
code
I voted 17 so very very exciting a lot
of people signing up and I actually
should check out the discord server I'm
seeing one of our mods say that it's
been a good time on discord gloom skull
can you post how many people have been
on like what's the most that the biggest
number of people that you've seen on the
discord server I'm curious what's going
on there like I imagine it's sort of
like the CompuServe chat rooms of 15
years ago of the the earlier internet
I'm wondering what it is that that goes
on there like is it you know is it like
a is it I'm guessing it's not like a
phone sex line of any kind I'm guessing
it's political discussion or something I
don't know
NWA has sent a to Canadian dollar super
chat saying does James Jackson nullify
Trump's travel ban I don't know what
you're talking about is James Jackson
the guy that went to
New York City and shot black people
let's see if it is let's see James
Jackson yeah I think it is that guy no
it doesn't really nullify the travel ban
travel ban I don't really I'm not sure
that I completely understand the
question five dollar super check from
Courtney Hanes saying have you talked
with Kyle kolinsky about the Russia
thing my impression is he's a bit fed up
with it and thinks Democrats need to
move on I have not spoken to Kyle about
the Russia thing Kyle and I did a sort
of simulcast type thing a week or so ago
and we did not talk about the Russia
thing but I'm not totally up to speed on
what Kyle's view is on the Russia thing
I know people have been emailing me
saying Kyle doesn't believe it and I
just don't really know what that means
right now but I am more than glad to
talk to Kyle and listen anybody I don't
know what Kyle said but if your argument
is Democrats need to move on from the
Russia thing the Russia thing this
should not be partisan okay if a foreign
power has colluded with a candidate to
manipulate the election that is an
infringement on the sovereignty of
American elections and it shouldn't be
partisan it's big ly partisan that's how
it's that's how it's become but it
really shouldn't be big thank you to
Jennifer mitts who has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership by the
way i've been getting some epic epic
hate mail lately and i've been posting a
bunch of it to my instagram if you don't
if you're on instagram by the way i am
like so close to 5,000 followers on
instagram so please follow me there
David Pakman and there's pictures of not
only me flying a drone
there are screenshots of the hate mail
I've been getting lately and it's been
escalating quite a bit there are
pictures of me with my dad's dog known
to some on the chat as adderall dog so
there's a lot of exciting stuff
happening on my Instagram on that note I
have 2% battery left on my phone because
this was a completely impromptu
to livestream so rather than get
disconnected when my phone dies I will
wrap up the chat now please do support
the work we're doing david pakman.com
slash membership use the coupon code
I voted 17 if you want get a 40 percent
discount I promise I'll do another live
stream very very soon